est ce que c'est votre dernière campagne
et vous personnellement est-ce que c'est
ma dernière le pad
certains disent c'est sa dernière
campagne pourquoi vous avez toujours
voulu un novice la suivante sur le pen
certains disent que c'est votre canton
c'est le dernier
me pose souvent la question monsieur le
pet à ce que c'est ma dernière élection
au niveau des je n'en sais rien
j'attendrai que le patron sonne le
rappel
java et vous savez pas de doute c'est
loin c'est maurice est nouveau c'est
vrai
mallette jamal est tenu john's et
messieurs bonjour
hier je parlais de 2,2 du foulard de la
burqa et tout ça tu l'écoutés le fulleur
à un avantage foulard islamique
c'est que il permet de voir le voir
c'est une minorité visible et il faut
qu'on voit la minorité visible avant
qu'elle devienne une majorité visible
puisse compenser le fait que dans la
liste du npa et d'une femme qui soit
soit l'ex confession musulmane et non
ses baladins cbl oui je crois que j'ai
la photo il avait gelé ilham c'est la
dame à la voix la différence qui enfin
le le foulard et cela régulier vraiment
moshtarak être honnête quoi pire alors
voilà la burqa c'est ça voilà à la tête
de liste plein d'idéal
c'était un sujet et bien voilà alors là
c'est ça c'est le défilé de mode
d'hermès là c'est le poulet un joli joli
le problème c'est de savoir si on voit
le visage ou pas pour le reste c'était
ça n'est pas ça qui est essentiel c'est
essentiel les roms à celle non loin de
là la petite lattier daltrey but portait
une burqa mais à mon avis pourquoi
j'ai un peu de finesse et messieurs si
je n'avais pas d'autres questions à
poser leur mercie jaffa ça marche et ses
pittoresques un bon gars
caroline mais tous bords de la rivière
tu verras pas c'est le cas d'agents a
fait tomber savoir ce que c'est une
photo penser tout bas oui j'ai en fait
quand j'étais jeune et aux petits même
ses miaulements
j'ai fait quatre ans cher
au sommaire ginola la salle après des
cafés de luxe non un ami gérard aimé
giral du faux ce que j'ai mis 10 et j'ai
tourné les documents ainsi que d'avoir
deux
ça change plus c'est que s'engage une
responsabilité mutuelle vous allez
chercher aujourd'hui de vie restent à la
maison laval cisep à chaque foyer
oui mais vous comprenez les gens nous on
a tellement eu de gens très sympathiques
et quand on ouvre le journal il y avait
les photos épouvantable
moi je ne sais pas je vous connais pas
plus que celles vendues
c'est normal je savais qu'il fallait
changer parce que le photographe propose
comme photo si les phases une faute
horrible le rédacteur en chef il la voit
pas c'est ici si celle ci devant sa
photo à l'humanité comme il serait trop
mais ça va être serré très populaire
s'est réjoui que la photo soit 20 min
après ça j'ai acheté une maison de
campagne pour permettre à mes enfants
quel était le 15e de voir les vaches du
côté de mathieu de voir des arabes
bah il avait eu droit aux jo et moi
j'achète pas j'ai pas peur de la
poursuite la chute poursuivi alan doss a
poursuivi je suis l'objet d'une enquête
ensuite une plainte de sos racisme parce
que j'ai dit que 90% des faits divers
étaient le fait d'immigrés ou de
descendants d'immigrés alors ça c'est
pas permis de dire ça c'est si j'étais
ump on dirait que c'est un dérapage
moi je n'ai pas cherché au pistou but
j'ai un esprit le chemin aller à sa
majorité
apprenez votre vivre mais là c'est la
france va croiser
cet objectif
mais nous sommes sûrs merci
en tant qu'enjeu pillent les lieux
alors certes reste comme ça je pense
pierre bien comment benzema bien je ne
la prennent pas parce que je pense qu'il
fera des gros bisous de ma part j'ai dû
manquer pareille et petit à petit à
petit fille avant de la retourner tous
les garçons sont plaints du rhône elle
puisque je vais sur internet et on
essaie vainement veille sur l éco prêt à
manger comme un dragon
d'accord là encore des petits n'enfants
dernier ce dimanche le site annonçant va
je crois que le nombre de candidats non
par quelques billets la bad le psg c'est
ça le problème c'est qu'ils sont tous
ces gens tous d'autres non oui oui bien
sûr enfin toujours bon j'ai vu des
filles c'est l'inconvénient l'heure
c'est l'heure va commencer il ya trois
listes d'extrême droite a pas de listes
dissidentes du fonds teralys décidant
mais ce sont des anciens de l'udf et de
la ligue du sud
12h10 et merci m s mais tous ces délices
assure des anciens du front national est
toujours des gens qui n'ont jamais rien
n'était dans leur vie que par le front
national
ils n'ont aucun titre que d'avoir été
ancien conseiller du front national
ancien conseiller régional du front
social ancien député il faut un
rationnel en dehors du front national
ils sont rien et quand il essaie
d'exister comme a essayé de le faire
monsieur carl lang secrétaire général du
mouvement pendant 15 ans avec deux
députés européens en tête de liste et
county et 16 conseillers régionaux
il a fait 1 % le second merci et se
moque t payer
ses collants
le
merci
merci madame était à tous j'ai tout seul
les seuls collèges
voilà j'en mangeais
cinq jours
cinq journées protéines légumes je vais
voter cinq journées pratique
il
moi j'ai
montpellier a
voici
aujourd'hui le sol target plus tôt
ap
je
je tiens tout d'abord à vous remercier
évidemment comme l'a fait tester tout
cela aujourd'hui aussi nombreux et
motivés et je souhaite aussi salué
particulièrement nos amis venus de
midi-pyrénées
si enfin et surtout est infiniment jean
marie le pen qui a accepté de venir
soutenir notre liste aujourd'hui
le savons tous sont la paix tout à
l'heure encore il est particulièrement
sollicité qu'il est lui aussi en pleine
campagne régionales en provence alpes
côte d'azur et que le président de notre
mouvement consacre beaucoup plus encore
de son temps à ses responsabilités
nationales et médiatique il y a dans le
monde un milliard en moins de gens qui
meurent de faim ou cha mais je disais
dans mes discours que j'étais plus jeune
la différence entre le monde et nous
c'est qu'il ya eu mort d'homme qui se
lèvent le matin en se demandant comment
ils vont manger et j'ai déjà 50 de gens
qui ce n'est lorsque demandant comment
ils vont maigrir mais ça l'était oussama
et dames et messieurs
ça ne durera pas et vous n'avez qu'à
ouvrir les yeux dans vos rues pour déjà
avoir une idée de ce qui peut nous
arriver
lassé des idées de ne pas passer
j'aimerais vous changez donc voilà ce
que je pense au plus près des jeunes
j'avais quand on a eu marre qu'on ne
change pas non plus n est jamais été
nominé à créer une marque et sans
changer il faut des milliards seuls ceux
qui ont beaucoup beaucoup d'argent qui
permettent de changer de nom mais la
jouvence de l'abbé schumi oui ça va
changer
le président lit à un moment où rim et
je viens pas pour voir la ville vient
pour voir dans sa garde et regarde bien
un petit bonjour comme est sous sa
protection
parce que tu
là
tu perds ton temps flash ferrière bah
oui moi pour moi oui mais pas pour toi
c'est bon
bonjour secrétaire-général de cette
venue déposer de ses sièges
le côté nous comptons sur vous
moi je sais pas
soit 6 centimes sous le sourire parce
que c'est le négoce à perrine boutons de
manchettes et le pôle inès et plusieurs
avec ces deux là oui alors c'est pour ça
je vais les romains ceux qui sont
entreprend dans l'âme alex hamilton
oui bonjour jusque là bien moi je il
faut surveiller un petit peu les blocs d
notamment celui de la provence puisque
j'en vois sous les yeux l'arc en date du
6 mai qui vient d'écrire à nouveau
croiser à la brosse et paca est en 15e
position sur la liste du sud on y va
quand au président du groupe
un plaisir du groupe c'est monsieur
boudreau et michel macary a été exclu
ainsi d'ailleurs que je suis beau regard
il ya déjà un certain temps
oui d'accord vieux mais l'acheteur
donald sous les yeux là il faut les lire
et même à les surveiller un petit peu et
les rectifier immédiatement ça c'est là
une chose nouvelle pour y aller c'est
passé au quai branly ou fax aussi
électif accès aux services d adhésion de
la ligue du sud ne passera ce qu'on
vérifie qu elles sont seules et qui sont
éventuellement membres de mouvements et
de toutes les déférer tout en commission
disciplinaire ok c'est visible bien on
fait le un petit peu l'agenda nous
envoie avec la journée le débat a lieu à
partir de 15 heures alors ce matin il ya
les votes à midi à laval à y aller vote
à midi mais le premier vol réussi d'un
vote sur un accord-cadre sur les
relations entre nous parle des copains
et les commissions tiennent donc je
pense à 12h à doha bon dès 12h à 12h30
ou glv on doit déjeuner de nos
empreintes au coin de l'âtre puisque
vous montrer notre langue reprise du
débat la reprise du débat et ensuite
l'élection d'une nouvelle commission
élection de la nouvelle commission
ça se fait par des milliers de votes ça
soit
c'est tout
si avec ça
la m
avant
et ça
le centre le sens dans le sang
c'est grâce à laurent
les doigts d'or
je
c'est
pas mal
bonjour
j'ai cinq ans et plus
vainqueur
comment tu vas christian faisait même
pas bonjour je suis un peu touché et
nuits sont très brefs lorsque morgan
gérald voilà
ce qui est ici le floch de kaffrine
je
b
mesdames messieurs mes chers amis je
remercie particulièrement notre
président de sa participation dans sa
présence à notre fête de l'autre
fédération du bas-rhin
une fois de plus je remercie également
d'autres nice président bruno gollnisch
est ainsi que mes amis conseillers
régionaux des autres départements
patrick et martin bader et je dois
également excusé marine le pen pourrait
bien aider notre pays qui était trop
prix qui avaient un programme trop
chargé aujourd'hui qui donc s'est excusé
kristen comme nazi habashi comme l'asie
abah abah
il faut rassurer
m
pour la mairie on dirait
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des gens
c'est l'exacte bien mari ne s'est pas
dit croyez quatre enfants et non 6 4
il
au malus marina bay
dans les salles mais je m'étais j'avais
pas vu ce qu'il dit
aujourd'hui
passe bien
ce que je vais dire c'est parfaitement
ordonnées dans par rapport à tout ce que
tu as dit et tout ce qu'a dit répond
plus aux seuls intérêts
hier un challenge entre nous non
challenge un défi on va les finir
challenge en français c'est comme les
j'ai remarqué que les speakers de
l'autiste de la radio dix banques hoover
vancouver s'est donc ouvert c'est
pendant son mandat il faut dire 20 du
groupe
pour lutter contre l'insécurité il faut
remettre en cause d'abord et avant tout
l'immigration massive qui a pour
conséquence de tes racines et qui a pour
conséquence de déracinés de leur culture
traditionnelle des millions d'individus
de les jeter dans un mode de vie qui les
bouleverse qui leur fait perdre l'an
reste leurs repères gens cherchent trop
et dans lequel il acquiert le pire de
notre culture tout en gardant le pire de
la leur
dossier au bureau national c'est qu'on
m'a dit lorsque ans et allemandes
samedi on savait qu'il a 8 ans ce
bouquin oui mais je suis sûr c'est que
j'ai achetées ailleurs
ah bon d'accord comme ça ma fille
constant sont assez bien de vous par la
suite c'est la constance
quel âge elle a trahi deux ans
mais vous avez déjà du jour sous le bras
avec 130 ans mais ces lieux c'était
jésus parce que oui c'était vraiment
qu'est ce qu'il était bien le moment de
dire on était avec jean-marie je fais
tout le monde dira avant l'été
sanaa
j
alors là nous sommes dans la rue du
marché ce sont les côtés conducteur ce
qu'ils produisent eux-mêmes avant qu'ils
montent directement qui vendent
directement sont de moins en moins
nombreux parce que la vie de présenter
d'ici peu
ah les moines occupant la grotte où est
donc un
c'est rare vous savez que la région est
grande plus le pas et pourtant si vous
avez des billes on annonce aussi que
peut-être attendre aux menaces que ça
grossit est glauque pas non plus avec
tout ce qu'il est grillé désunion
vas-y
il
mais je me cachais kivu
elle s'adresse à fond
on vous laisse faire ce qu'il faut périr
perron et je me sens bien comme ça je
crois
c'est la dernière ligne droite monsieur
le pen oui presse vous aimez ça les
campagnes je ne les aime pas mal mais
vous vous souvenez plus que les autres
fois non pas plus non pas moi je me
donne au maximum et je ne compte pas eux
mêmes on ne compte pas l'avant vous
savez je viens d'être élu l'année
dernière députés européens pour cinq ans
je vais être élu conseiller régional
je vais aussi longtemps que bon dieu me
prête vie voilà je considère que ce que
ce fait est plus important que ma vie ou
que mon confort ce que j'ai à dire pour
l'avenir de mon pays pour sa sauvegarde
pour sa sécurité
plus important que tous ces prix
bon on se rejoint le modem on peut
augmenter c'est vrai quand on est en bas
qu'est ce qu'il voit une grande
dynamique
un déficit
oui c'est sûrement mois
oui un stylo sur un silo no
tammy ces gens qui pleuraient gentili
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est jean ziegler
vient d'apprendre en arrivant ici
d'abord deux personnes très aisées l'une
de l'autre
je vais vous lire un texte il a pris la
france et n'en sait rien faire
dieu sait pourtant que le président se
démène l'homme qui après sa prise de
pouvoir a épousé une princesse étrangère
est un carriériste avantageux
il aime la gloriole les paillettes les
grands mots ce qui sonne ce qui brille
toutes les verroteries du pouvoir victor
hugo dans napoléon le petit avouez que
vous pensiez à un autre
joe kals pic à 2
c'est bien petit peu plus molle
avez vous créé la source de la des
plaintes ont été déposées contre notre
organisation de jeunesse
l'objet qui a motivé de la part des
jeunes
la fiche qu'ils ont fait c'est ça ça
c'est le tee shirt que l'on porte
couramment dans les rues de marseille
notre mère marseille problème
voilà un c'est pour ça que la fiche que
je trouve assez drôle d'ailleurs c'était
assez démonstrative et toujours un petit
peu évidemment comme est normal la
publicité un petit peu accessible c'est
normal c'est le rôle même de la
publicité qui consiste à vouloir attirer
l'attention des gens n'attire pas
l'attention avec un tableau pas remplies
claire quoi c'est sûr il faut un peu de
couleur dans tout ça voilà ce qu'ils
peuvent aller ailleurs à ce que j'ai
écrit qu'elle voit pas dans le noir
c'est à lui dire danois fallu dire dans
l'homme de couleur quand on part de la
fiche j'ai dit mais voilà voilà le tee
shirt que portent les jeunes français de
papier
moi j'en ai besoin pour le procès peut
avoir à ben oui d'accord tu veux
vraiment prendre des photos d'accord et
ça il est couramment portée de main
c'est l'exploit
quatre pages sur la paca avec une grande
photo double page de monsieur vauzelle
puis sur l'autre page monsieur corps et
ça pèse 1 a retiré mariani et godin et
puis vici
ce qui est le pen il a droit quand même
à une ligne avec eux je dis pas plus on
déjà la nourrice on leur mettra le
journal de rachel roy a tenu une ligne
j'ai droit à la non mais il cherche
surtout pas faire ça annuel des jeunes
et ne faut pas nous déjà les affiches du
fn
monsieur vauzelle la juge raciste
oui demande son interdiction ah oui il
fait par les bombes à signer donc son
interdiction mais sur quel fondement
tout le monde dans la main cette affaire
est cool de la scandaleuse
elle incite elle incite clairement au
racisme et à la haine moralement et
juridiquement le racing doit être
condamné
à l'est
attention à ces 2010
moi je dénonce et se fait par cette
affiche est âpre et non plus par la cie
12 ans
bonjour
cette affiche à viande trois choses non
à l'islamisme
non à la burqa et non et non à l'emprise
algérienne
son autre pays comprend bien ceux qui
sont contre nous disent l'inversé ils
disent oui à l'islamisme oui à la burqa
est oui alors prise algérienne que
chacun prenne ses responsabilités
politiques
voilà
photo doc
vaillant mais ça va les alertes et
remercie plaisir et joie conseille
d'apprendre d'eux alors oui c'est ça
monsieur même jean-marie oui
injuste je suis allée lui prendre
l'ascenseur réserver nos trucs bloqués
il a bloqué la source à ok
ouf course folle il interprète un vite
battant gilles chercher la fiche de quoi
la colère la fiche non ah bah oui
on voit très bien par de merveilleux
alors que les femmes président va parler
dans sa meilleure configuration 200
dockers vibreur je n'ai pas eu un
résultat est le même et bien selon jean
marie le pen au second tour
11 271 direction à la charmante c'est
quand même le président alors jean luc
mélenchon on va peut-être entendre jean
marie le pen qui est en direct à louis
hémon son allant bonsoir humour bonsoir
bonsoir m'écoutais je crois que c'est
une victoire du front national qui était
annoncé comme vaincu mort enterré par le
président de la république eh bien il a
montré qu'il était toujours une force
nationale et probablement de plus en
plus grande au fur et à mesure que les
échecs à la fois de l'ump et du ps se
révéleront aux yeux du public car la
vérité il s'agit d'un riche monsieur le
pen qu'est ce que vous voulez faire de
cette force deuxième tour mais cette
force au deuxième tour a assuré
l'élection des conseillers régionaux
front national par conséquent il faut
que les gens au deuxième tour renforce
encore l'effort qui l'ont fait de façon
à ce que le front national soit une
force française trompe attentes qui soit
capable de redresser ce pays qui est
actuellement dans un état épouvantable
non
je poussais de goûter à la fin beaucoup
mais ça suffit
nous affichons qui leur a tant au début
ils ont repris le plateau désolé que ça
qu'on n'est pas et c'est là j'ai alors
voulu qu'il fasse sa commande parce
qu'il ya déjà la demande grecque alors
redescendre à sa soeur la chanteuse ella
innocents dans des courriers des
classeurs arrivera dans le requiem non
je vais défendre la cause interrogés en
bas tu veux la garder à l'esprit la
mishna ritondale là ça fait le buzz sur
le pupitre
j'ai déjà un super mec j'ai reçu des
mails ah ben ça fait sept mois quand
c'est trop c'est lors que la médication
quelques cheveux
je
au mieux
c'est une déroute c'était parti
politique ump et ps ses deux grands
partis disposant de toute
l'infrastructure politique de la france
ne mouillez un considérable à la fois
dans les conseils régionaux les conseils
généraux les conseils municipaux 36000
conseil modifiant son réseau légal avec
valérie létard pourtant ministre de
nicolas sarkozy
heureusement ça
ces résultats des régionales établit
aussi une hiérarchie quand à votre
succession avec notre fille qui sait le
deuxième meilleur score et qui donc
naturellement se pose en candidate la
plus crédible mais je ne savais pas du
ne vont pas pris ça en considération
nous sommes uniquement intéressés par
les élections régionales
et ça nous préoccupe suffisamment comme
ça sans que nous ayons à y ajouter
d'autres préoccupations qui viendront en
leur temps tout naturellement comme cela
se fait dans les congrès des partis
politiques au front national comme les
autres un quart d'heure
60% hector je crois selon une étude
d'opinion rejette la droite et la gauche
et bien cela peuvent voter pour le front
national est lancé un signal extrêmement
fermes au gouvernement
excusez moi je dois y aller réveiller
encore un bureau politique et jeu
les oreilles congrès et je ferai
connaître je serais très très
certainement candidat
je crois que j'ai un certain nombre de
qualités c'est pas parce que je me les
attributs ou comme je les reconnais que
je dénie scène les qualités tout à fait
positive de marine ou éventuellement
d'ailleurs d'autres concurrents c'est
pas parce qu'on est on serait
compétiteurs dans cette perspective qu
on tire pas la marque dans le même sens
moi je valais
aussi dit penser que nous sommes dans
les routes de france
on peut plus vous avez qu elle aimait
mauvais mais non savent même pas lire
mon nom dessus sur la liste d'accord
d'accord
oui bon l'orthographe du nom c'est pas
grave c'est en traînant estropiés ton
âme en jetons gérard parce que l'on
prenne encore qui continue avec le major
dans le malheur de me joindre
donc ça les amis voilà mais je n'ai pas
la légitime question des âges ne
rapporte pas si tu n'aimes pas état
comme ça ça va mais si je me suis vous
qui croit que je le prends la monnaie au
contraire j'ai aucun problème car on
marque que on en est on est des causes
et kokoïty ils appellent ça oui c'est là
la dynastie le pen la saga le pen
il parle alors de jamal jarrah si voilà
c'est ça allait le château de motion le
jeu non non non non on voit là bas noirs
le manoir sexuellement bain noir piano
noir dedans donc c'est c'est plus
amusant dans ses puits manager mick dans
le minute ou deux minutes pour la gauche
vous serez tous et à toutes
c'est là un petit studio cette petite
cabine jallet fonctionne bien
joker asker effacés je ferme la porte
les matinales de l'entre-deux tours
après l'ump le ps europe écologie place
ce matin au front national invitée de
france inter et en duplex du bureau de
france bleu à marseille président du
front national bonjour jean marie le pen
bonjour vous allez quand même prendre
votre retraite bientôt est passé à main
sans doute à votre fille non je ne
prends pas ma retraite du tout je viens
d'être élu député européen pour cinq ans
et je vais probablement être conseiller
régional pour quatre ans puisque la
durée du mandat a été limité
donc c'est pour 87 ans la retraite de
jean marie n'est pas non non je n'ai
belle je déteste le mot retraite aussi
bien sur le plan militaire que sur le
plan civil alors je ne prendrai pas de
retraite j'ai c'est le bon dieu qui sera
mon départ j'obéis fait à ce moment là
vous n'aurez jamais gouverné jamais
exercé de responsabilité vous aurez
passé votre vie a protesté
ça suffit sa politique c'est vrai
pendant longtemps le tribun de la plèbe
c'est celui qui qui dit tout haut ce que
les gens murmurent tout bas
le tribun de la plèbe mais qui va
refiler sa charge à sa fille donc ce
aristocratique où avez vous lu ça il ya
un congrès au front national c'est le
congrès qui décide ça départ le
président si c'était le président je
l'aurais fait tout naturellement
vous savez je ne suis pas le seul homme
qui est des fils et des filles on en a
il y en a aussi dans le journalisme chez
de marmara là il y en a dans le chai des
artésiens dérivé du tout y en a chez les
muses il ya des images de musiciens jean
marie le pen on vous retrouve après la
revue de presse après la chronique
politique de jean-marie colombani
c'est-à-dire dans une dizaine de minutes
j'aime ça
radio scoop quoi très bien
namli ce beaucoup plus de monde beaucoup
plus notamment de journalistes qui ont
vu
d'intervenir en congés anticipés
comme si le score réalisé
redonner de l'intérêt à ce violent de la
politique que beaucoup avaient déjà
enterré
c'est pour
en provence alpes côte d'azur maintenant
notre estimation la liste de michel
vauzelle largement en tête avec 44% 33,5
pour tirer mariani jean-marie le pen
fait un score encore plus important
qu'au premier tour du nouvelliste
attention
il a à présent
estimation de la préfecture
si la prudence
dans le voir 75005 alpes-maritimes
la trois élus bouches-du-rhône but est
lui un peu d'autres provence ces acquis
blacks ont sauté
du coup
et l'autoroute 10
oui
merci
papeete merci qui
mesdames et messieurs et conseillers la
séance est tous bien
en ma qualité de doyen d'âge de cette
assemblée je suis appelé à présider la
première partie de cette séance
consacrée à l'élection du président du
conseil régional
permettez à votre doyen d'âge qui a
beaucoup vu en soixante ans de vie
publique de faire un tour d'horizon
dans l'ensemble la campagne électorale
fut d'aton correct
à l'exception d'un candidat socialiste
qui pour éviter d'avoir abordé la
question de son bilan s'est dérobé au
débat pourtant élément essentiel en
démocratie en affirmant qu'il refusait
de parler je cite auf assister au fas
six ans qu'il me soit permis de lui
rappeler que le fondateur du fascisme
fut un député socialiste italien benito
mussolini que les deux principaux chefs
de la collaboration avec l'allemagne
nazie pendant l'occupation furent marcel
déat ancien secrétaire du parti
socialiste et ses filles au et j'aime
doriot ancien secrétaire du parti
communiste et que ce n'est pas
jean-marie le pen qui a été décoré à
vichy de la francisque mais le président
de la république françois mitterrand
dont monsieur vauzelle a été ministre et
qui plus est ministre de la justice
monsieur moser york obtenu la majorité
absolue est élu président du conseil
régional je l'invite à prendre sa place
on recueille de présidente du conseil
régional
m